hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game you guys requested as soon as
it finished it is from the penultimate
round of this year's Superbad rapid and
Blitz Tournament being played in Poland
so this is the eighth round of the
Rapids and it's Yankees of Duda versus
Maxima shella Grava features the move
from the thumbnail uh as you uh probably
uh or already have imagined uh let's
dive straight into it there is quite a
lot to enjoy so young has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to D4 we
have Pawn to D5 C4 and now uh not the
not the Queen's Gambit declined but
actually the Queen's Gambit accepted and
it is what we mostly enjoy nowadays
there are so many games in the Queen's
Gambit declined once we see uh Queen's
Gambit accepted we know that it's
probably going to be a treat and usually
Knight to F3 is the most paid move here
but now we have Ponte E4 and this means
that it will be an incredibly sharp game
so Pawn to E5 challenging Maxine Central
uh do the Central Pawn structure and now
Knight to F3 we have Bishop to B4 with
checks still captures on D4 is the most
common and Maxim wants to mix it up a
little bit Bishop to B4 check Knight to
C3 and now Knight to F6 uh he offers the
full Center for this Ponta B5 move and
then it's just a very very unbalanced
and anything can happen on both sides so
Knight captures an E5 and pawn to B5 so
now do that with the wonderful central
control here as you can see and Maxime
with his pawn and C4 being defended and
if this Knight somehow finds his way all
the way to D3 it's gonna be great for
example 96 the B4 to D3 could be a great
square and in fact it will happen but
not uh not in the way probably Maxime
imagined it so here Pawn to F3
strengthening the pawn here as the
Knight here is pin so you need
additional support for that E4 Pawn we
have castles and now Ponte A4 Duda goes
after the B5 pawn pawn to C5 Maxim goes
after the strong Center because dudas
King is still in the center of the board
Bishop to E3 and now C captures on D4 we
have Queen characters offering a queen
trade and queen to E7 Maxim just moves
the queen out of the way now The Rook is
coming to d8 with tempo of course the
queen is on D4 a captures on B5 and now
Rook to d8 putting pressure on uh do the
screen here Queen captures on C4 and now
Bishop to E6 getting more moves in uh
all with Tempo Queen back to E2 and now
Queen to C7 and there is a game that
reached this exact same position uh last
year it was played between pranav Anand
and Pregnant and that game ended in a
robot in that game Knight to C6 was
played here we have Knight the C4 as
could the queen is attacking the Knight
and it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
Maxine deals with this novelty we have
Knight beat the D7 continuing
development and now Rook to A6 looks
like a very active move Duda goes for
Rook to A4 a very uh forcing idea uh uh
now Maxima has to figure out what to do
with the bishop does he go to back to C5
Bible for a trade of dark Square Bishops
maybe go back Bishop to E7 he decides to
trade here Bishop captures on C3 and
pawn characters and it is a bit of a
weird idea because you undouble and I do
response but Knights the C5 now and Rook
the B4 we have Knight to D3 with check
as advertised the Knight he does come to
D3 but also as advertised not in the way
that Maxim imagined it because here Duda
does not move the king and you can't
really move the king if you move the
king then you go under the mask of the
rook and you just resign Queen captures
on D3 Duda gives up the queen Rook
captures and Bishop captures okay a
queen for rook and the Knight not uh not
uh not a bad deal but if you put this
position to an engine the engine will
give a firm 0.00 pretty much any line
you play it's 0.00 so let's see how they
continue Knight to D7 with Bishop to D4
now excellently uh centralized and also
controlling that Knight on D7 uh very
nicely as you can see we have on the A5
great move by Maxine forcing Duda to
capture not really forcing you could
also ignore it but I mean for a rapid
game no one can calculate what happens
here if you play B6 uh this is uh I mean
pretty scary stuff Queen to C6 now
Knight captures on A5 you give up the
Nitro captures and now Pawn to B7 look
at this The Rook cannot go back you
cannot go back with the queen so the
best you have is a rook A1 check Bishop
blocks and now you have to block with
the Knight for example White Castles and
this is a it's a very very different uh
thing that uh than what actually
happened in the game it's something
maybe Rashid nej Medina would play uh
but uh in maybe in a classical game here
Duda just plays a b captures an A6 Alpha
Song Rook captures an A6 and now he just
castles the safety and okay uh you still
have the bishop pair you have the Knight
The Rook uh the past C Pawn so you do
have a definitely compensation for the
queen we have Rook to A8 and The Rook F
the B1 doubling up on the B file we have
Pawn to H6 Maxim has to create some
breathing room for his King and now
Bishop back to F1 you don't want your
Bishop to be a Target on D3 and from F1
he will be defending the king side plus
also supporting the advancement of the C
Pawn once the Knight moves so here King
to H7 and now Knight the E3 preparing uh
the C Pawn to start advancing and Maxine
finds a way to stop this he plays Queen
to D6 now of course C4 will be met with
Queen captors and D4 so Knights the D5
Duda offers a pawn but you can't really
take it Maxim does trade here Bishop for
Knight captures captures but now do you
see the trick if Queen capture son D5
the trick is uh look at the King on a
light Square uh Bishop to D3 check
that's the trick and now it doesn't
matter what you play with working
digital G6 because the bishop now comes
to E4 and you nicely
um secure the queen and the Rook will
fall so after he captures on D5 we have
Pawn to G6 Maxim spots this he stops the
the bishop check and now Pawn to C4 this
is how Duda starts advancing his two
connected pass pawns uh due to the
tactic uh Rook to A2 and now dude that
just brings The Rook back he wants to
trade Rooks and in fact this would be
the best for example Rook captures will
captures Queen F4 let's see it attacks
the bishop Bishop to F2 and you still
fight but um you don't feel great not
not in the least those pawns are now
marching forward and it's questionable
whether you can stop them or objectively
yes you can stop them but in a rapid
game very hard to say however uh Maxine
played Queen before he gives up The Rook
just in order to eliminate the bishop
pair not the but not the full Bishop
pair just the half of the bishop pair
but if you eliminate one Bishop then the
bishop Perry is eliminated it's a weird
thing to say I know but what are you
gonna do Rook captures an A2 Queen
captures and D4 with check King to H1
and now Pawn to H5 now Maxim knows that
the pawn uh pawns are unstoppable and
his only hope is H4 H3 remember that is
his only hope and now we have Rook to A1
and now Pawn to H4 we have rooked the D1
attacking the queen queen to F2 and now
feel free to pause the video and to win
the game for Duda while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
to do it congratulations on listening
what I said twice and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Ponte H3 this is what Duda played
and it was in this position on move 34
uh that Maxima shellegra resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here you have no no hope here uh the the
reason why I said you you have to stop
H3 is that let's say you play Rook 8 to
C1 and that's kind of your plan you want
to put the Rooks behind the past pawns
and then just Advance the pawns there's
nothing black can do about this here if
you don't stop H3 then H3 for black is
uh kind of dangerous okay you're not
gonna lose but you're not gonna win
let's say C5 now the Knight comes into
the game c six Knight captures and F3
and it's a force to draw G captures
Queen captures and you're not getting
away from checks Queen E3 checking each
one Queen F3 check and so on here after
they spawn the H3 move there is nothing
yes you do have a knight and you can
even get this Knight all the way to G3
it doesn't matter to give you an example
let's say Knight to F6 you can just
continue pushing the pawn the six Knight
H5 D7 now light the G3 with check King
H2 and you just don't care I mean the
queen and Knight combo is deadly even
the Knight is defended on H4 but even
all that is not enough in this position
there's no good continuation you can
like capture ones but it doesn't really
matter Queen G3 checking each one next
you're just gonna put the Rook behind
the pass pawn and promote that pawn to a
queen and easily winning position so
yeah incredible stuff and incredible uh
how always when the queen government is
not declined it is accepted the uh you
know the games like uh these will happen
and they don't set for nothing they said
like okay you have Gambit but the
Queen's Gambit isn't really a Gambit
like you're not gambiting anyway
accepting the Queen's Gambit is
extremely dangerous uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it
they're brilliantly done by Young
Schuster of Duda uh not all of the games
have finished from the final round but
uh for the moment as I'm recording in
this video Duda is in the lead I will at
least make one more video from the final
day of the super bet rapid in Poland and
we're we are going to discuss the
standings after that yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank David Kimura I am the
reason Enthusiast group golfsoftware.com
Gary Shaw for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World Plus
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions as usual so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day